il nous fait l'honneur de reprendre son
personnage ses personnages favoris
il va nous faire un bâillon faible coït
avec nous c'est parti les yeux quand je
veux pas mais qu'elle revient de venise
avec un souvenir qui aura la queue entre
les jambes commencent à dit comme ça
mais ce soir on faible
alors que laurence plance je crois je
n'avais pas eu de face
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si on arrive à faire 10 bonnes réponses
fois qu'un canot montrent au public
s'est pas tu te sens l'engagement alors
vas-y tu démarres pas commencé ben ali
kazem où chercher ouais c'est parti
conjuguer le verbe savoir à la première
personne de l'imparfait du subjonctif
baisse les yeux encore at il fallu que
suspect c'est la bonne réponse
attention on continue oui ça va oui top
comment les gens du voyage appelle-t-il
un autobus rempli gags la caravane
fallait savoir annoncions rapport auquel
j
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel footballeur français blond aux yeux
aux cheveux longs a marqué un but en
finale de la coupe du monde 98
la même taille que vous emmanuel petit
[Musique]
tiens ça vaut se cogne combien y at-il
de bosses tient chaud se cogne combien
tu me réponds moi oui s'il se cogne deux
fois quatre fois les suivre attention
alors laurence attention je rappelle que
ce n'est pas avant de téléachat s'est
pas remis à temps appelle tout un
élément fixe situé sur le quai pour y
amener un bateau beatles alors vous
n'aurez pas cette question trop facile
pour vous continuez
comment comme quoi le hasard fait bien
les choses une vie d'alors michael a
changé une lettre aux mots à nice pour
faire un autre mot anus et y avait aussi
à vis à vis one attention pervers mais
quels sont les 21e et 22e lettres de
l'alphabet saleh le savoir iv
[Applaudissements]
jamais tu m'as tu vu qu attend paris oui
à peut-on trouver dans la vitrine d'une
boulangerie dans le slip d'un homme un
gant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
patry un robot qui soit pour de rigoler
quel moustachu était à vos côtés pendant
plusieurs années europa pierre bellemare
y avait aussi valérie benali brouch sur
place la bête doha comment s'appelle la
phobie des lapins lapinou phobie taqwa
lapine of black à la levrette la
canicule c'est parce qu'elle dit
d'hermaphrodites trouve-t-on au bois de
boulogne
c'est pas très bien fait attention on
regarde dans les yeux
quelque chose comme une aristo arrive à
faire un footballeur et un ouvrier du
btp
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui peut être pétanque de feu
ou de neige bull
oui laurence j'apprenne au maire de
lower salavert de panda 3 ans for peace
passes et uche bouffer lampaul la mère
de paul comprenez qu'elle est le slogan
de mnm ce qui peut également s'appliquer
à vos soirées coquines fond dans la
bouche attention question rapidité
qu'est ce qu'un volet michel en marchant
comme la couleur qu'il fallait vite
parmi ces villes françaises qu'elles
n'existaient pas pour que très courroucé
plus on fout c'est pire il ya un mot sur
ces trois centraux ketchup mayo que
peut-on maintenant son kebab algérienne
oui ça moi il m'a vu qu un cyril de la
question quelque chose que vous n'aurez
jamais à vos chroniqueurs parce que vous
êtes une grosse basse
[Applaudissements]